Hello.
I will now introduce you to the
concept of similar triangles.
Let me write that down.
So in everyday life what
does similar mean?
Well, if two things are similar
they're kind of the same but
they're not the same thing or
they're not identical, right?
That's the same thing
for triangles.
So similar triangles are
two triangles that have
all the same angles.
For example, let me draw
two similar triangles.
I'll try to make them look kind
of the same because they're
supposed to look kind of the
same, but just maybe
be different sizes.
So that's one, and I'll draw
another one that's right here.
I'm going to draw it a little
smaller to show you that
they're not necessarily the
same size, they just are
same shape essentially.
One way I like to think about
similar triangles are they're
just triangles that could be
kind of scaled up or down in
size or flipped around or
rotated, but they all have
the same angles so they're
essentially the same shape.
For example, these two
triangles, if I were tell you
that this angle -- and this is
how they do it in class.
If I were to tell you this
angle is equal to this angle
and I told you that this angle
here is equal to this angle.
Well, a couple of things.
You already know that this
angle's going to be equal to
this angle, and why is that?
Well because if two angles
are the same, then the third
has to be the same, right?
Because all three
angles add up to 180.
For example, if this is x,
this is y, this one has to be
180 minus x minus y, right?
That's probably too
small for you to see.
But that's the same thing here.
If this is x and this is
y, then this angle right
here is going to be 180
minus x minus y, right?
So if we know that two angles
are the same in two triangles,
so we know that the third one's
also going to be to same.
So we could also say this angle
is identical to this angle.
And if all the angles are the
same, then we know that we are
dealing with similar triangles.
What useful thing can we
now do once we know that
a triangle is similar?
Well, we can use that
information to kind of figure
out some of the sides.
So, even though they don't have
the same sides, the ratio
of corresponding side
lengths is the same.
I know I've just confused you.
Let me give you an example.
For example, let's say that
this side is -- this side is 5.
Let's say that this side is,
I don't know, I'm just going
to make up some number, 6.
And let's say that this
side is 7, right?
And let's say we know that, I
don't know, let's say we know
that this side here is 2.
So we know the ratio
of corresponding
sides is the same.
So, if we look at these two
triangles, they have completely
different sizes but they
have corresponding sides.
For example, this side
corresponds to this side.
How do we know that?
Well, in this case, they
just happen to have
the same orientation.
But we know that because
these sides are opposite
the same angle, right?
This is opposite angle y,
and then this side is
opposite angle y again.
This whole triangle might be
too small for you to see, but
hopefully you're getting
what I'm saying.
So these are
corresponding sides.
Similarly, this side, this
blue side, and this blue side
are corresponding sides.
Why?
Not because they're kind of on
the top left because we could
have rotated this and flipped
it and whatever else.
It's because it's
opposite the same angle.
That's the way I always
think about triangles.
It's a good way to think about
it, especially when you
start doing trigonometry.
So what does that us?
Well, the ratio between
corresponding sides
is always the same.
So let's say we want to figure
out how long this side of
the small triangle is.
Well there's a bunch of
ways we could do it.
We could say that the ratio of
this side to this side, so x to
7 is going to be equal to the
ratio of this side to this side
-- is equal to the
ratio of 2 to 5.
And then we could solve it.
And the only reason why we can
do this -- you can't do this
with just random triangles, you
can only do this with
similar triangles.
So we could then solve for x,
multiply both sides but 7 and
you get x is equal
to 14 over 5.
So it's a little
bit less than 3.
So 14 over 5, so 2.8 or
something like that,
that equals x.
And we could do the same thing
to figure out this yellow side.
So if you know two triangles
are similar, you know all the
sides of one of the triangles,
you know one of the sides of
the other triangle, you can
figure out all the sides.
I think I just confused
you with that comment.
So, this side, so
let's call this y.
So we could do the same way.
We could say y over 6 is equal
to 2 over 5, Right Make sure if
you're doing one triangle's
going to be the denominator
here, then that same
triangle has to be the
denominator on the--.
If one triangle is the
numerator on the left hand side
of the equal sign, right, so
the smaller one's
the numerator.
Then it's also going to be the
numerator on the right hand
side of the equal sign.
I just want to make sure
you're consistent that way.
If you flip it then you're
going to mess everything up.
And then we can just solve for,
so y is equal to 12 over 5.
So, let's use this information
about similar triangles
just to do some problems.
So let's use some of the
geometry we've already learned.
I have two parallel lines, then
I have a line like that, then
I have a line like this.
What did I say, I said that the
lines are parallel, so this
line is parallel to this line.
And I want to know if this side
is length 5, what is -- well,
let's say this length is length
5, let's say that this length
is -- let me draw
another color.
This length is, I
don't know, 8.
I want to know what
this side is.
Actually no, let me give you
one more side just to make sure
you know all of one triangle.
Let's say that this side is 6,
and what I want to do is I want
to figure out what this side is
right here, this purple side.
So how do we do this?
So before we start using any of
that ratio stuff, we have to
prove to ourselves and prove in
general, that these are
similar triangles.
So how can we do that?
Let's see if we can figure
out which angles are
equal to other angles.
So we have this angle here.
Is this angle equal to any
of these three angles
in this triangle?
Well, yeah sure.
It's opposite this angle right
here, so this is going to be
equal to this angle
right here, right?
So we know that its opposite
side is it's corresponding
side, so we know that it
corresponds to -- we don't know
its length, but we know it
corresponds to this
8 length, right?
I forgot to give you
some information.
I forgot to tell you that
this side is -- let me
give it a neutral color.
Let's say that this side is 4.
Let's go back to the problem.
So we just figured out these
two angles are the same, and
that this is that angle's
corresponding side.
Can we figure out any other
angles are the same?
Let's say we know
what this angle is.
I'm going to do kind of a
double angle measure here.
So what angle in this triangle
-- does any angle here
equal that angle?
Sure.
We know that these are parallel
lines, so we can use alternate
interior angles to figure out
which of these angles
equals that one.
But I just saw the time
and I realize I'm
running out of time.
So I will continue this
in the next video.